le directeur de la rs un pouvoir qui est
relative relativement important même
très importants notamment vis-à-vis des
établissements de soins voilà dans ce
qu'on reproche donc aux ars et si vous
voulez là le premier confinement a été
quand même certains déclencheurs bien
qu'on avait déjà des d'autres histoires
avant mais le premier confinement nous
avons eu un ordre dans les
établissements de soins de déprogrammer
des patients qui était donc programmée
pour des pathologies dont il souffrait
ce qui fait que les médecins qui sont
dans ces eaux dans ces établissements de
soins n'ont pas travaillé
les patients ont une perte de chance
puisque leurs interventions ont été
reportés voire pour d'autres ont même
été re des programmes et la laddh au
deuxième confinement et tout ça donc
parce que les établissements de soins
sont aux ordres de la rs puisque la rs
menace de la coupe et des financements
si jamais il ne glisse pas voilà donc
c'est déjà un exemple de ce que peut
faire la rs un autre exemple ça peut
être mort a par exemple l'achat d'un
scanner dans une ville eh ben la rs
décide si on met le scanner à l'hôpital
ou à la clinique de la ville et en
général deux coups sûrs trois ans on
s'aperçoit que c'est à l'hôpital
voilà donc ces voyait donc il ya tout un
ensemble de choses qui sont de façon
autoritaire et dont même les
établissements de soins et les libéraux
encore mois sont consultés dans leur
pratique quotidienne
ce que je reproche c'est que un c'est le
bras armé de l'état etc en fonction du
directeur de la rs et de sa personnalité
ont peu ou pas discuter avec lui la
gestion de la pandémie elle s'est faite
au niveau départemental et régional par
les ars et il y a eu en fonction des
départements et des régions
des réponses qui ont été plus ou moins
d'adapter on l'a vu par exemple avec la
gestion des deee du privé ou dans
certains départements on sait pas
pourquoi les établissements publics
étaient blindées
voilà avec des lits drea surchargées des
services surchargé et à côté des
services du privé qui était vide à
certains endroits et qui n'ont pas du
tout participé à l'effort de prise en
charge
voilà sa première question pourquoi cela
alors que la rs a pour vocation 1
aujourd'hui
de gérer dans son dispositif peuvent sur
sur le soins sur les territoires
aujourd'hui l'un des gros soucis pour
moi le rsc le souci de la chaîne de
commandement c'est à dire il ya le
ministère dans leur d'ordre on a les ars
et on a les établissements deuxième
point les ars parce que c'est là aussi
il faudra analyser la chose c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est arrivé au
niveau de la pandémie à une telle
situation sur le sol français
c'est un secret de polichinelle pour bon
nombre de d'initier au niveau de la
fonction publique hospitalière que dans
certains départements eh ben les ars
sont en contact direct et permanent avec
les directeurs financiers des
établissements et toutes les semaines on
harcèle les directeurs financiers pour
savoir combien ce qu'on appelait
d'économies combien on a terminé
combien on a on a débauché de personnel
combien il ya de contractuels pour avoir
des variables d'ajustement
ça a été comme ça et c'est comme ça
depuis de très nombreuses années
je serais plutôt sur le fait de dire que
les ars sont quand même nécessaire
puisque l on il faut quand même gérer le
territoire donc de façon rationnelle et
on peut pas faire d on peut pas
multiplier par le nombre de bassins de
vie et les espaces de décision donc déjà
la prévention c'est de voir les gens à
des âges clés de la vie pour essayer de
limiter donc jugé en les les colosses
qu'on appelle les comorbidités ensuite
je mettrai les médecins donc au centre
avec une organisation de surveillance et
de coordination avec les pharmaciens et
les infirmiers je rappelle que les
infirmiers ont un massage des infirmiers
libéraux ont un maillage territorial qui
est très bien ils sont très bien
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
voilà ça ça serait un système idéal et
en dernier ressort
l'hôpital puisque à ce moment là on ne
peut plus se soigner les gens à domicile
et donc on les envoie à l'hôpital au
niveau départemental et au niveau
régional juste à quel niveau de décision
on laisse une structure qu'elle
s'appelle ars qu'elle s'appelle drass
qu'elle s'appelle d'as qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont que pouvoir de décision c'est ça qui
est important et c'est surtout aussi au
niveau des finances que ça soit des ars
que ça soit des draps
ddas c'est pas ça qui est important
c'est quelle politique on veut et
berckois on veut aller
est-ce qu'on veut continuer à aller vers
des établissements où on centralise tout
non des gros chu avec des tout petits
établissements autour qui vont se
retrouver en difficulté parce que les
personnels n'auront pas envie de venir
parce que eh ben il y aura des manques
d'effectifs parce que les services sont
pas très attractif parce que les bills
sont des petites villes il ya plein de
choses aussi dans dans le fait de revoir
les territoires et ne rendra quatre îles
des territoires qui vont faire que les
choses vont évoluer pour les médecins
c'est pareil pour les médecins est ce
qu'on va ouvrir numerus clausus est
réellement l'ouvrir et non pas comme ils
l'on a lancé et qui ne l'ont pas fait
parce que les effets vont se faire
sentir dans sept à huit ans auparavant
donc on a vraiment besoin de revoir tout
ça est de mettre en musique aujourd'hui
ses décisions pour prévoir l'avenir
parce que diriger c'est prévoir
[Musique]